Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Eight: the Faroe Islands.
Færøernes geografi, the geography of the Faroe Islands.
The Faroe Islands are a group of islands consisting of 18 islands, which lie in the Atlantic Ocean between Scotland, Iceland and Norway.
The islands' total area of 1,400 square kilometres corresponds roughly to that of Lolland.
The Faroe Islands have 55,000 inhabitants.
About 14,000 of them live in the capital Tórshavn, which is also the largest town in the Faroe Islands.
The landscape is marked by steep, grass-covered cliffs.
The highest point, Slættaratindur, lies 880 metres above sea level.
The Faroe Islands have a climate with mild winters and cool summers as well as large amounts of rain.
The winter in Tórshavn is thus, in spite of the northern location, a little warmer than in Denmark.
The rest of the year it is however somewhat cooler than in Denmark.
The weather often changes quickly, and despite the small size of the country there is often a big difference in the weather from island to island.
The history of the Faroe Islands.
The Faroe Islands were first populated in the 600s by Irish monks who settled on the islands.
The monks were however quickly displaced by Vikings from primarily Norway, who carried out an extensive settlement of the Faroe Islands.
Thereby the Faroe Islands became part of the North Atlantic cultural and trading community.
During the Middle Ages the Faroe Islands came under the Norwegian king and thus followed in 1380 with Norway into the union with Denmark.
The Faroe Islands got their name from the Old Norse word fær, which means sheep.
That refers to the many sheep that are raised on the islands, and which up to the 1800s were the Faroe Islands' most important industry.
And wool and clothes made of wool were the islands' by far biggest trade goods with foreign countries.
The Danish king gradually got direct control of the trade on the islands.
The Faroese could only sell their goods at fixed prices to Danish merchants, and from 1708 only to the Royal Monopoly Trade in Tórshavn.
Conversely, Denmark had a duty to supply the Faroese population with necessary goods from outside, for example grain, timber, iron and salt.
Denmark could however not always protect the islands, which therefore often got visits from foreign smugglers and pirates.
Among other things, the islands were in 1629 attacked by North African pirates, who killed six persons and carried off and sold about 30 as slaves in North Africa.
The Faroe Islands came under the first Danish constitution in 1849 and were thereby also represented in the Folketing and the Landsting.
Trade with foreign countries was made free in 1856, and from the end of the 1800s the Faroe Islands developed into a modern, international fishing nation.
It was especially the large cod fishing that now became the islands' most important trade good.
Since the Reformation in the 1500s, the church, the administration and the school had been completely dominated by the Danish language, while Faroese for centuries survived especially as an oral language through a rich tradition of folk songs.
Only in the middle of the 1800s was an official Faroese written language created, which, together with a rising national awareness, was decisive for the Faroese language surviving and for it today being the main language on the islands rather than Danish.
When Denmark in 1940 was occupied by the Germans, the Faroe Islands were occupied by Great Britain.
The islands had great strategic importance for the transport routes between the USA and Europe, and therefore the British wanted to prevent Germany from occupying the islands.
Great Britain did not interfere further in Faroese politics, and therefore it became possible for the Faroese to govern more themselves than they had been used to under Denmark.
When Great Britain after the end of the war in 1945 gave the Faroe Islands back to Denmark again, the wish for independence on the islands had grown considerably.
After the Second World War, negotiations began about a home rule arrangement for the Faroe Islands.
A referendum in the Faroe Islands however showed a very small majority for independence from Denmark.
Most politicians in the Løgting, as well as the Danish government, did not regard the result as clear.
After a new election to the Løgting, agreement was reached between the Faroe Islands and Denmark about home rule for the Faroe Islands, which therefore remained in the realm community with Denmark.
The Faroe Islands got home rule by law in 1948.
The home rule consists of the Løgting, which is an elected and legislative assembly, and an administration led by a government, a landsstyre, that is the political leadership.
The Løgting can have up to 33 members, elected for four years at a time.
The chair of the government, the lagmand, is elected by the Løgting.
The Løgting passes the laws in all areas the home rule has taken over.
These include, among other things, social services, education, tax, housing, fishing, raw materials in the subsoil, municipal matters, culture and leisure, and infrastructure.
In 2005 the Faroese home rule arrangement was expanded.
The Faroe Islands can today take over all areas, except the state constitution, citizenship, the Supreme Court, foreign, defence and security policy, and currency and monetary policy.
The Faroe Islands receive in 2025 an economic grant from the Danish state of about 575 million kroner a year.
Fishing is by far the most important export income source for Faroese society, but also shipping and tourism have great importance for the economy.
When Denmark became a member of the EF, the EU, in 1973, the Faroe Islands chose to stay outside.
That also means the Faroe Islands can enter their own trade agreements outside the EU.
Christianity generally plays a bigger role in social life in the Faroe Islands than in Denmark.
There are still many Faroese who go to church on Sundays.
While Denmark introduced free abortion in 1973, and a large majority of the Danish population supports free abortion, there is greater disagreement on the issue in the Faroe Islands.
Only in 2025 did the Løgting adopt introducing free abortion on the islands.
It applies up to the 12th week of pregnancy.
17 members of the Løgting voted for and 16 against, and thereby there was only just exactly a majority for it.
Until now the law has only allowed abortion if the woman has been raped, or if the pregnancy threatens her life and health.
Faroese cultural life.
The Faroe Islands have a rich cultural life.
Authors such as the two cousins Jørgen-Frantz Jacobsen, who lived from 1900 to 38, and William Heinesen, 1900 to 91, are known both in the Faroe Islands, in Denmark and in several places abroad.
Jørgen-Frantz Jacobsen's main work is Barbara, which came out in 1939, the year after his death.
The novel is set in the 1700s in the Faroe Islands.
Barbara is a younger woman who falls in love easily and also has great attraction for men.
Everyone in the small, religious local community has an opinion about Barbara.
It is told, among other things, that it is her "sin" that is to blame for the death of her two earlier husbands, two former priests, and for having seduced the new priest.
Like the Faroe Islands' wild nature and harsh and changeable weather conditions, Barbara's nature also cannot be tamed and has a great effect on the local community.
The theme of social deviance, that is when people's way of life does not fit into a small local community with narrow limits for right and wrong, also recurs in William Heinesen's main work De fortabte spillemænd, "The Lost Musicians", from 1950.
At the centre of the story is a group of musicians who live a life with music, alcohol and women.
The hardworking, thrifty and religious local population has difficulty accepting this "dissolute" way of life, and therefore the musicians cannot fit in and gain a foothold and stability in life.
In recent years the poet Vónbjørt Vang, born 1974, has made herself noticed.
In 2025 she received the Nordic Council's Literature Prize for the poetry collection Svørt Okidé, "Black Orchid", which is about a mother's fear of losing her teenage son, who has disappeared into abuse of alcohol and narcotics and later into the psychiatric system.
Also Faroese painting is at a very high level.
Faroese painters often paint Faroese motifs such as the wild nature and life in the small villages.
But in a way and with a choice of colours which raises the Faroese up to something that all people can recognise.
The Faroe Islands' flag is called Merkið, "the Mark".
It was drawn up in 1919 and is a flag of the Nordic type with a cross and with the colours white, blue and red.
Since Denmark had been occupied by Germany in 1940, and the Faroe Islands by Great Britain, the British demanded that it should be possible to distinguish between Danish and Faroese ships, which until then had also used Dannebrog.
Therefore Great Britain approved Merkið as the Faroe Islands' flag on the 25th of April 1940.
Every year on the 25th of April the Faroese gather for public meetings to celebrate their flag.
You typically hear a flag speech and sing community songs.
The flag is also seen in every town in the Faroe Islands on the 29th of July, which is the Faroese national day.
On this day the Ólavsøka, the Olaf Festival, is held, which is named after Olaf the Holy, who was king of Norway and died in a battle on the 29th of July 1030.
Most of the Faroese of that time were descendants of Norwegian emigrants, and therefore Olaf the Holy has become the Faroe Islands' patron saint, that is the saint who is said to protect the Faroe Islands.
Here is your recap for Episode Eight.
The Faroe Islands have 18 islands in the Atlantic Ocean between Scotland, Iceland and Norway, an area of 1,400 square kilometres, similar to Lolland.
There are 55,000 inhabitants, about 14,000 in Tórshavn.
The highest point is Slættaratindur, 880 metres.
Irish monks arrived in the 600s, and then Vikings from Norway.
The islands followed Norway into the union with Denmark in 1380.
The name comes from the Old Norse word fær, meaning sheep.
The Royal Monopoly Trade existed from 1708; trade was freed in 1856.
The Faroese written language was created in the middle of the 1800s.
Great Britain occupied the Faroe Islands in 1940, and gave them back in 1945.
Home rule by law came in 1948 and was expanded in 2005.
The Løgting can have up to 33 members, and the chair of the government is the lagmand.
The Danish grant in 2025 is about 575 million kroner.
The Faroe Islands stayed outside the EF in 1973.
Today neither Greenland nor the Faroe Islands is part of the EU.
Exams round the populations: the Faroe Islands, 55,000, may appear as about 50,000, and Greenland, 57,000, as about 55,000.
Free abortion up to week 12 was adopted in 2025, by 17 votes to 16.
Authors: Jørgen-Frantz Jacobsen wrote Barbara, 1939, and William Heinesen wrote De fortabte spillemænd, 1950.
Vónbjørt Vang won the Nordic Council Literature Prize in 2025.
The flag, Merkið, was approved by Great Britain on the 25th of April 1940, which is Flag Day.
The Faroese national day is the 29th of July, with the Ólavsøka festival, named after Olaf the Holy.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
When was free abortion introduced?
Option A: 1935.
Option B: 1951.
Option C: 1973.
[DA] Hvornår blev der indført fri abort?  A: 1935  |  B: 1951  |  C: 1973
The answer is C: 1973.
It appeared in the November 2020 and June 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: 1973
Question 2.
How many inhabitants do the Faroe Islands have?
The exams round the figure.
Option A: About 55,000.
Option B: About 155,000.
Option C: About 255,000.
[DA] Hvor mange indbyggere har Færøerne?  A: Cirka 55.000  |  B: Cirka 155.000  |  C: Cirka 255.000
The answer is A: About 55,000.
It appeared in the June 2026 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Cirka 55.000
Question 3.
What is the largest town in the Faroe Islands called?
Option A: Reykjavik.
Option B: Nuuk.
Option C: Tórshavn.
[DA] Hvad hedder Færøernes største by?  A: Reykjavik  |  B: Nuuk  |  C: Tórshavn
The answer is C: Tórshavn.
It appeared in the November 2022 and November 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Tórshavn
Question 4.
Which symbol is part of the Faroe Islands' flag?
Option A: A circle.
Option B: A star.
Option C: A cross.
[DA] Hvilket symbol indgår i Færøernes flag?  A: En cirkel  |  B: En stjerne  |  C: Et kors
The answer is C: A cross.
It appeared in the May 2023 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Et kors
That's the end of this part.
Well done.